[Music]
john is in atlanta hi john welcome to
the ramsey show
hey there dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
not much
my wife and i are in baby step two
we have about
153 000 in debt
we are toying with the idea of
potentially selling our home in order to
become debt free wow 153 count the house
no it does not what's that on there's
about
there's about 235 on the house okay how
much what's the 253
the the 153 yes i'm sorry most mostly
student loans
how much is student loans
no
i don't have it exactly how much is a
car not in front of me of
27. how much is the boat
no vote
okay
um what else is in there besides a car
and a student loan
that's about it we paid off our all of
our credit cards are gone gotcha what's
your household income we paid off about
two we paid off about 25 000 last year
good for you what's your household
income
uh around 130. okay
good okay
what's the house worth
i haven't had an appraisal on it um but
trending in that area uh that house
would probably go for around 400. okay
okay
all right uh
do you like the house
we like the house but it's
not a
i think we're both at the point now
where
renting an apartment for a year or two
doesn't sound like such a bad idea
um 100 debt free
9 and 11 yeah yeah 100 debt free sounds
awfully fun
yeah it does
okay
and you've been working on this for a
year
yes sir okay
all right this question often comes up
when people first start
and if it's when you first start i'll i
will tell you to try it for a year and
see how it goes
and see what you can come up with
because selling a house is very
expensive emotionally
financially
tears up your time
it takes a chunk out of your year you
know there's just a it's a it's not as
simple as uh
you know taking a taking a pair of jeans
back to the store that didn't fit i mean
it's a problem you know what i'm saying
right
right
yeah it's taxing on you and that's why i
it's the last thing i tell people to do
is to sell their house and if you told
me you didn't like it that would help
you know but all you're saying is it's
an okay house but we're at the point
that we we can see that this is going to
take us
you know this is going to take us three
hard years
almost maybe even a little bit more or
we can give up this house and be done
with this
right and this is the trade-off
yeah
there's not a wrong answer
john it's it would be a matter of uh
personal preference
uh what would sharon and i do if we were
ambivalent about the house meaning we
were kind of in the middle we don't care
one way or the other we'd probably sell
it
because we would we would relish the now
that we know what it feels like to be
debt-free we would relish that idea more
than we would home ownership for the
next because in one year you can save up
a down payment start the process again
right
right
yeah so go live in an apartment for one
year with everything paid for tight
budget
build you up a nice emergency fund a
nice down payment and then go buy you a
house on a 15-year fix where the
payment's no more than a fourth of your
take-home pay
and so you're one year out of the
housing market
you're taking advantage of this white
hot market right now
uh one year or
18 months from today it will have calmed
down from where it is now somewhat i
don't know how much but it will have
calmed down it's not gonna get worse
uh it's crazy out there right now so um
great time to sell uh that's another
reason to think about it so yeah we
probably would
but if you guys talk about it tonight
and you go you know we're just really
good we're gonna gut it out we're gonna
fight through this for three years and
knock this debt out and keep this house
that's not a that's not a wrong answer
okay because there's nothing here that's
demanding that you do this it's a matter
of
you are making the choice between
making a move
apartment for a year buying another
house
uh 18 months later
give or take and you're making that
choice between that and being debt-free
today or fighting for three years that
that it's just the trade-off of that and
that both of those are things that give
you a good outcome
five years from now
five years from now with either way you
go you're going to be in great shape
got it so just make the choice which way
you want to play this but i probably
wouldn't it wouldn't
i don't own any houses i'm that tied to
i like real estate but there's stinking
house on every corner so i just don't
get all jacked up about houses
um
so i probably i i'm out of there because
houses to me are just commodity i don't
i don't get a lot of emotion about them
but um but but
sharon might argue with me on that so
and then i might let her win because she
does often